ah
[Música]
les voy a contar una historia imagínense
a una niña de 12 años que estaba
haciendo a que jugaba cómo se vestía
como era la relación con sus papás
imagínense a esta niña que día con día
se levantaba de su cama con la ilusión
de ir a la escuela sexto de primaria
para ver a todos sus amigos
a esa edad no te querías comer el mundo
estoy segura de que si yo quería hacerlo
eso a todos nos sentíamos invencibles no
medimos los riesgos nos sentíamos los
más fregones como superhéroes pero al
mismo tiempo nos rodeaba una inocencia
profunda
además de todo esto la niña de la que
les hablo iba muy bien en la escuela
tenía buenas calificaciones se llevaba
con los más grandes e incluso se podría
decir que era popular pero un día todo
esto cambió una compañera celebraría su
cumpleaños en cuernavaca sería de ida y
de regreso e irían amigos y amigas de la
persona de la que les habló así que
porque ya no iría claro que fue y tan
pronto llegó corrió con una amiga a la
habitación donde estaban sus cosas para
cambiarse por el traje de baño y así
poder ir a nadar pero mientras buscaban
entre las maletas y la ropa tirada en el
suelo se encontraron con una sorpresa
una botella de vodka de principio se
sorprendieron pues quien sería capaz de
llevar una botella de alcohol a una
fiesta de niños y niñas de 11 y 12 años
se imaginan alcohol eso que tanto vemos
y escuchamos siempre si hace datos nos
queríamos comer el mundo imagínense a
ellas así que claro que la aprobarían
así ya nadie les tendría que decir cómo
huele a que sabe o que se siente
el alcoholismo en jóvenes crece
actualmente la edad de inicio es de 13
años pero qué tan rápido y cuánto daño
le puede hacer una niña de 12 años una
botella de vodka con 40% de alcohol
con el efecto de este alcohol estas
amigas comenzaron a bromear ya tomarse
fotografías entre ellas y como resultado
una fotografía de la niña que les habló
con el torso desnudo
esta fotografía que la amiga prometió
que borraría dos días después la tenía
toda la escuela así es una amiga una
niña mandó la foto
es una zorra ya la viste qué [ __ ] no
comentarios de este tipo no se hicieron
esperar pero saben de dónde vinieron las
críticas más incisivas las más dolorosas
y agresivas de las mujeres
y esto es justo lo que vengo a decirles
el día de hoy de la violencia de las
mujeres hacia otras mujeres es decir
cuántas veces no hemos escuchado a
mujeres decir comentarios de este tipo
refiriéndose a otras mujeres por lo
menos yo he escuchado miles de veces me
lo han dicho a mí se lo han dicho a mis
amigas y lo mismo al redes pues ellas lo
dicen
la violencia hacia las mujeres va en
aumento
somos las primeras en juzgarnos y en
menoscabar la dignidad de la otra
ejemplo de esto es la niña de la que les
hablo que con tan solo 12 años de edad
fue expuesta por una amiga
su fotografía estaba en los celulares de
todos por lo que un día la dueña y
directora del colegio decidió ir a
visitar a la mamá de la niña para
enseñarle la dichosa fotografía y
contarle lo que había sucedido pero por
supuesto una versión muy diferente a la
de la niña que sonaba algo como tu hija
precoz decidió mandarle la foto a equis
niño de la escuela la mamá asustada
corrió con el papá y juntos decidieron
acercarse a su hija quien les contó la
verdadera historia
en un principio fácil la historia que yo
les cuento
sonaría algo como sexting que se define
como el acto de enviar fotografías o
vídeos con contenido sexual explícito a
través de internet pero en realidad fue
mucho más que esto sin embargo méxico
ocupa el primer lugar en sexting en
américa latina pues 4 millones de
jóvenes y niños entre los 6 y los 19
años si 6 años afirman que han enviado
contenido de este tipo o que conocen a
alguien que lo ha hecho y cerca del 20
por ciento de adolescentes entre los 17
y los 20 años afirman haber reenviado
contenido así
existen muchísimos casos que incluso han
llegado a la policía y no hay que irnos
tan lejos para esto pues en la ciudad de
mexico a unos 20 kilómetros de aquí una
niña se enteró que había sido violada
por un vídeo que vio circulando en redes
sociales
hay que entender que esto tiene como
desenlace el hostigamiento y el bullying
hacia la persona es por esto que la niña
después de platicar con sus padres
necesitaba tomar la decisión de si
volvería o no a la escuela ella ya no
quería volver se sentía atacada e
invadida de muchas maneras pero para la
escuela también era importante que ella
no volviera lo pueden creer no solo pasó
de ser la responsable sino hacerla
culpable pues claro es más fácil
castigar a una que a todos los demás
involucrados
así es como esta niña después de que el
tema no volvió a salir en la escuela
decidió que ya no iba a seguir ahí
pronto harta de leer todos los mensajes
que recibía en su celular hostigándola
insultándola y criticando la decidió
tomarse una caja completa analgésicos o
con el único objetivo de no tener que
volver a leer algo parecido en su vida
pues el ciberbulling o el ciberacoso
como una forma de violencia a través de
internet es un fenómeno que también ha
ido creciendo
pues cerca del 16 punto 22 por ciento de
niños y adolescentes entre los 10 y los
17 años afirman haber sido víctimas de
alguna forma de este y en lo que
respecta a la modalidad de enviar
fotografías que ridiculicen ofendan es
casi el 10 por ciento y en el casi 25%
duran más de dos semanas tiempo
suficiente para verdes enlaces negativos
y fatales en cada historia
afortunadamente esta niña mejoró después
de un par de noches en el hospital pero
pues a todo esto la niña de la que les
hablo era ella
soy yo era mi fotografía eran mis amigas
y yo intenta acabar con mi vida hace
ocho años
después de un par de meses mi mamá
decidió que no era posible que yo
siguiera tirada en la cama y así poco a
poco comencé un proceso de recuperación
y de aceptar lo que en realidad había
sucedido
fui era una niña de 12 años que se había
enfrentado por primera vez a su cuerpo a
su sexualidad a mis amigas ya mis notas
amigas a las manos de mis compañeros a
mis compañeras a las maestras y a la
directora y si se convirtió en una
realidad sentir una tacada por mi propio
género
en un méxico tan lastimado como en el
que vivimos hoy en día es absurdo no
pensar en la violencia de género en los
abusos en los feminicidios es por esto
que nosotros deberíamos de comenzar a
construir redes de apoyo a partir de
acercarnos conocernos y consolidar
nuestras relaciones no sólo con amigas o
con familiares sino con desconocidas
hay que comenzar a voltear no saber a
nosotras mismas hay que darnos cuenta de
que ese feminismo por el que luchamos no
es posible si seguimos hasta juzgándonos
por la forma de vestir hay que
permitirnos ser libres ser nosotras
dejar de competir y ser cómplices pues
nos conviene esta es la única forma en
la que nos vamos a lograr ayudar pues si
no lo hacemos las mujeres entonces quién
lo va a ser y yo ya no quiero hacer la
[ __ ] ni que mis amigas lo sigan siendo
gracias
[Aplausos]